Oh  [Music]  [Music]  want some dank a Sbarro's our place I'm  going to the boardwalk coming  are you guys just gonna stay down here  all right we're just going exploring  where that peninsula across the bay  sounds like an adventure  [Music]  get support  [Music]  you're right  I waited but no one showed uncle to ZP  we leave a buried here  don't tell anyone  finding decent no place was a bus it's  real  we're so lucky tell me what's berry here  or I shall read and when you learn  riding in that mess when you're done  playing the bad boys I promise you pal  red he's gonna be in jail I've been  hearing rumors that my friends have been  talking to the police I think he'll be  more interested in it  breath crazy and read the sunlight  people people lie you need to stand up  do that comics this is your origin story  are you gonna grow up to be the good guy  or the bad guy  [Music]  I don't know you should do  [Music]  you